[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait au convoi de manifestants
anti vaccin anti passe notamment au
canada qui font des émules en nouvelle
zélande et maintenant en france ces
camions autoproclamé convoi de la
liberté ont démarré samedi devant le
parlement à ottawa et paralysent la
capitale canadienne depuis plusieurs
jours à wellington hier c'était aux
alentours du parlement néo-zélandais
qu'un mouvement équivalent bloquer la
ville en france un convoi se prépare
maintenant à rouler vers paris et
bruxelles ottawa a déclaré l'état
d'urgence le maire de la ville juge la
situation hors de contrôle critiqué pour
son silence le premier ministre justin
trudeau a finalement promis que le
gouvernement fédéral serait présent en
france bien sûr les autorités elles sont
en alerte alors qu'elle est ce mouvement
canadien dans un pays réputé plutôt
moins contestataire peut être que
d'autres et comment expliquer qu'ils
puissent paralyser la capitale ottawa
depuis une semaine quelle est l'ampleur
et la spécificité des autres mouvements
nouvelle zélande et maintenant en france
qui dit s'inspirer des convois canadien
quelles sont les réponses politiques on
en débat avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir avec nous à par skype de
montréal martin geoffroy bonsoir vous
êtes sociologue directeur du cfi re le
centre d'expertisé de formation sur les
intégrismes religieux les idéologies
politiques et la radicalisation
bienvenue à vous bonsoir nous avons
également duplex de bruxelles serge
serge jaumin bonsoir historien et
professeur à l'ulb et co directeur d
america le centre interdisciplinaire
d'étude des amériques bienvenue à vous
également
bonsoir
michel fize est avec nous au sociologue
auteur de qu'elle était belle ma
révolution des gilets jaunes au pass
sanitaires en passant par les gilet
rouge bienvenus
merci
nous avons également virginie herz avec
nous virginie bonsoir chroniqueuse
internationale à france 24 et puis nous
avons également notre correspondant sur
place a justement à ottawa françois
rihouet françois donc qui va démarrer
cette émission parce que tout a commencé
comme je le disais au canada en colombie
britannique notamment où le cortège le
plus important autoproclamé convoi de la
liberté quitte cet état pour se diriger
vers ottawa plusieurs milliers de
camionneurs ont choisi de converger vers
la capitale canadienne pour dénoncer
l'obligation vaccinale imposé à tous les
transporteurs qui reviennent au canada
après avoir passé la frontière
américaine une obligation également
valable d'ailleurs côté américain ils
ont donc traversé 4300 kilomètres
émaillé avant d'arriver à ottawa où ils
bloquent les alentours du parlement
toujours aujourd'hui on écoute tout de
suite le premier ministre canadien
justin trudeau il devait toujours des
individus essaient de bloquer notre
économie
notre démocratie
et la vie quotidienne de nos concitoyens
il faut que cela cesse les gens d'ottawa
ne mérite pas d'être harcelés dans leur
propre quartier
françois françois riou et donc à ottawa
on peut dire que ces fameux convois
n'ont pas écouté le premier ministre
canadien ils sont bien toujours là
oui effectivement petite précision nous
sommes de retour de t'avoir nous avons
passé les derniers trois jours en
reportage de retour ici au bureau à
montréal mais simplement pour revenir
effectivement sur ces chiffres ce sont
selon les autorités 1 et le chef de la
police d'ottawa à près de 3000 poids
lourds qui ont afflué vers la capitale
le 28 janvier dernier certains pour
seulement un jour ou deux et qui
effectivement 12 12 jours plus tard sont
toujours là selon les derniers chiffres
que nous avons pu collecter c'est un
millier de poids lourds qui sont dans
cette capitale d'ottawa et environ la
moitié d'entre eux dans ce qu'ils
appellent la zone rouge autour de cette
colline parlementaire où d'ailleurs les
débats à l'assemblée se sont poursuivies
et ont parfois été très vif entre justin
trudeau et l'opposition conservatrice
notamment ce sont donc cinq cents
camions toujours dans ces rues qui les
bloque certains ont enlevé leurs pneus
ils n'ont pas du tout l'intention de
partir et nous l'ont dit et répété ces
deux derniers jours il demande tout
simplement la levée de toutes les
restrictions sanitaires à travers le
pays tout ce qui est lié à la pandémie
et puis pour certains ils n'hésitent pas
à demander jusqu'à la démission du
premier ministre justin trudeau en
france fois
que disent les habitants de la capitale
ouais alors effectivement les habitants
de la capitale qu'on a pu croiser un
évidemment les riverains directs était
extrêmement fatigué après 10 11 jours de
klaxon intempestifs de jour et de nuit
beaucoup de bruit dans ce quartier de la
capitale administrative finalement et
les gens étaient extrêmement fatigué il
ya eu énormément de tension entre les
riverains et ces manifestants et les
chauffeurs de camions notamment il ya
une partie d'entre eux à travers le pays
selon les derniers sondages environ un
tiers qui comprennent le message porté
par cette manifestation cette demande de
la levée de certaines restrictions levé
kyi et dé facto effective à travers
certaines provinces en l'alberta les ces
dernières heures suite à l'évolution de
ce variant au micron finalement et donc
ils demandent de cette levée des
restrictions mais beaucoup condamne
finalement les deux tiers au moins
finalement qui ont été sondés et puis
évidemment les habitants d'ottawa con
anne la façon dont ces manifestants
procède occupe la place et parfois
finalement harcèlent les gens leur
demandent d'enlever leurs masques à
l'entrée des magasins
voilà et c'est de porter un message
assez violent sans parler du traitement
que certains manifestants pas tous
réserve aux journalistes aux
journalistes canadiens notamment qu'ils
assurent qu'ils accusent d'être des
messagers du diable d'être au service
d'un grand complot finalement et c'est
ce qu'on retrouve dans le narratif
encore une fois pour certains de la
mouvance kiwane merci beaucoup françois
martin geoffroy donc qui sont ils
françois parlait justement de mouvements
complotistes à l'instant est ce que son
ce sont des ultraconservateurs
principalement
menad à
la haye ce qu'on parle au canada ou à
ottawa on parle des gens qui sont à
ottawa en ce moment on va surtout parler
de ça voilà à ottawa et écoutez c'est à
ottawa c'est une collection de
groupuscules très variés vous avez des
groupuscules de l'extrême droite de
l'extrême droite du duo de l'ouest
canadien et vous avez des groupuscules
d'extrême droite du québec et par
exemple 7 cette manifestation d'ottawa
ce siège qu'on appelle maintenant a été
organisée au départ par un individu qui
s'appelait dan king est qui
et le chef lui en quelque sorte d'un
parti marginal dans la province
canadienne de l'ouest de l'alberta un
parti qui s'appelle le maverick partie
et c'est un parti d'extrême droite en
alberta qui désirent la sécession des
provinces de l'ouest du reste du canada
alors est à l'opposé de ça vous avez des
mouvements d'extrême-droite québécois
qui veulent la sécession du québec du
reste du canada et vous savez ce sont
des gens qui se parlent pas beaucoup
actuellement qu'ils ne s'aiment pas
beaucoup mais là ils ont une telle haine
de la démocratie libérale ils ont une
telle haine du gouvernement de justin
trudeau et des autorités en général qui
se sont réunis à cause des mesures
sanitaires dans une cause commune vous
avez aussi à ottawa des sectes qui sont
présentes à ottawa qui sont contre les
mesures sanitaires je pense que vous
connaissez en france les raéliens les
rats liens sont sur place les raëliens
québécois vous avez même une dame qui
prétend être la reine du canada
autoproclamé madame dit du lot
ça a été l'occasion ce siège parce qu'il
a été réussie jusqu'à un certain point
de réunir tous les gens qui en ont
contre les mesures sanitaires et qui
sont anti vaccin et qui ne sont pas
vaccinés en général vous avez aussi même
des influenceurs newedge qui vont se
retrouver là parce que il n'aime pas les
mesures sanitaires il n'aime pas la
médecine traditionnelle et la pandémie a
été une occasion ils ont ressenti un peu
plus le goulot se resserrer sur eux dans
leur terrible dans ce que ce qu'ils font
actuellement leur thérapie alternative
parce que ils ont pour la plupart un
discours
sur les vaccins que les vaccins par
exemple seraient des poisons je pense
que vous avez les mêmes discours en
france à que les vaccins seraient des
poisons qu'on veut pas se faire vacciner
parce que le gouvernement il ya
introduit des puces électroniques pour
nous contrôler et caetera et caetera et
derrière ça vous avez les des mouvements
d'extrême droite qui ont des idéologies
politiques très très arrêtées et dont
vous parliez des demandes qui était
faite au gouvernement canadien ottawa
oui on va y revenir justement de
l'aspect de l'aspect politique je vais
faire réagir serge de jaumin également à
ce que est ce que vous avez dit est ce
que ce sont donc plutôt un ensemble de
groupuscules c'est ce qui expliquait
martin geoffroy j'ai lu d'ailleurs que
c'était soutenu par donald trump par son
fils est également par elon musk qui
twitte un message d'encouragement aux
chauffeurs canadien qui assure at il dit
le milliardaire américain
oui vous savez parfaitement raison en
fait on peut dire que c'est une
coalition d'opportunisme d'opportuniste
c'est toute une série de personnes comme
on vient bien de le souligner qui
viennent finalement d'horizons très
divers qui n'ont pas grand chose en
commun si ce n'est cette opposition au
gouvernement fédéral et même par pour
certains à la démocratie canadienne donc
ça c'est vraiment un élément extrêmement
important toutefois il faut tout de même
aussi se rappeler que le premier élément
de cette manifestation c'est
l'opposition à l'obligation vaccinale et
sur ce point il faut dire que les
canadiens sont divisés et donc au départ
il y a de la part des routiers canadien
la volonté de dire très clairement qu'il
n'est qu'une partie d'entre eux en tous
les cas et c'est une infime minorité
parce que on considère que 80% 90% des
routiers sont vaccinés mais une petite
minorité qui ne l'est pas s'oppose au
fait que lorsque les chauffeurs
reviennent des états unis ils doivent
impérativement être vaccinés donc elle a
une obligation vaccinale que le
gouvernement leur a imposée comme il
impose également aux fonctionnaires et
c'est un élément très important parce
que c'est au tout deux de ses petites
éléments si je puis dire qu'il y à une
cristallisation des oppositions et donc
derrière ça le convoi qui s'est appelée
convoi pour la liberté a revendiqué la
liberté vaccinale mais aussi toute une
série d'autres libertés et c'est
important aussi de souligner qu une des
particularités au canada c'est que les
chauffeurs routiers sont généralement
des propriétaires de leurs de leurs
camions et donc ils viennent ils ce sont
des indépendants une fois en quelque
sorte ce qu'ils veulent avec leur camion
ce qui n'est pas le cas on ne répondra
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler il est
un élément important qui est en train
d'apparaître pour le moment c'est le
fait que sur toute une série de camions
mais il y a des autocollants qui
reprennent les noms d'une série de
sociétés et ça gêne beaucoup différentes
sociétés canadiennes différentes
entreprises qui se trouve là dans des
situations différentes dernier point
c'est particulier parce qu'ottawa est
réputée comme une ville extrêmement
tranquille il est très rare que l'on ait
de grandes manifestations et surtout des
manifestations de cette ampleur c'est la
toute première fois virginie à l'homme
avec partie est d'ailleurs le premier
tout premier parti justement à mobiliser
des fonds d'après ce que j'ai vu via les
réseaux sociaux pour soutenir tous tous
ces chauffeurs routiers certains
brandissent d'ailleurs le slogan de king
jong trudeau c'est allé très loin et
d'ailleurs ça vraiment bloqué parce que
là ce sont des routiers s'expliquer à
l'instant justement sergio main oui au
départ il faut rappeler effectivement
que ce sont des routiers qui se sont
mobilisés parce que sans vaccin il ne
pouvait pas s'en fassent vacciner ne
pouvait pas se rendre aux états unis et
donc c'est ça qui a cristallisé le
mouvement départ mais ce qui est ensuite
tout ce qui effectivement trouvé que les
mesures de confinement successives plus
l'obligation vaccinale était allé trop
loin se sont mobilisés autour de ça mais
au delà de finalement cette question du
du pass vaccinale finalement on a
l'impression que ce mouvement
agrège des déçus de la démocratie des
des gens qui font plus confiance les
unes sans une défiance vis-à-vis de la
démocratie une entente dans les
reportages de nos correspondants quand
ceux qui s'expriment qu'ils ne soient
extrémistes ou pas disent nous on veut
qu'on nous entende on veut qu on ait le
peuple nous aussi on est le peuple et
donc ils expriment un besoin
d'expression ils veulent s'exprimer
directement effectivement sans passer
par les institutions classiques dont un
dans lesquels n'ont absolument plus
confiance d'ailleurs dit what sap
douillet les réseaux sociaux ça c'est
des points communs qu'on retrouve en
france puisque en france donc six
convois de covoiturage ou de
particuliers à bord de leurs véhicules
sont en quitter leur ville bayonne nice
ou encore strasbourg les manifestants
vont vers paris ils vont se retrouver à
paris ce week-end et probablement
rejoindre bruxelles la semaine prochaine
pour une convergence européenne ont fait
le point
il se prépare à traverser la france pour
faire entendre leurs revendications
jusqu'à paris et bruxelles
[Musique]
leur slogan non au pass vaccinale oui à
la liberté à toutes les libertés
la liberté d'expression la liberté ne
pas être vaccinés la liberté leur ont
vendus surtout pour nos enfants nos
petits-enfants quoi me suis dans un pays
des bois je suis né libre il reste libre
c'est simplement la liberté et la
liberté la liberté la liberté de choisir
la liberté de vivre normalement
correctement librement
début du premier convoi français dit de
la liberté ce matin à nice ben voilà on
a vite fait aménager on a pris son
matelas il rentrait plus de poids dans
la voiture est bon là un peu de un peu
de vivres d'eau le nom du mouvement
vient du canada l'objectif est d'imiter
les routiers du trac l'antique on est le
peuple et on a le droit d'être ensemble
et de dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord il a
13 ans et je vois pas pourquoi on va
l'obliger à faire quelque chose qui lui
servir à rien on dira je suis dans le
médical donc j'étais suspendu donc j'ai
le temps à l'image de ce préparateur en
pharmacie
plusieurs personnels soignants suspendu
parmi les manifestants mais aussi
d'anciens gilet jaune le pass régional
n'a fait qu'accentuer leur colère
on a manifesté tous les pratiquement
tous les samedis et tout ça apparemment
lehman et ça bouge pas donc pas là il ya
eu ce set cette initiative de faire un
convoi
comme au canada on va essayer de le
faire si ça peut porter porté ses fruits
allons-y
contrairement au canada très peu de
camions pour l'instant mais quelques
dizaines de motos et de voitures
désormais sur l'autoroute le convoi
pourrait grossir au fur et à mesure des
villes traversées
michel fize qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire justement le fait que ces
mouvements fasse tache d'huile d'abord
nouvelle zélande maintenant en français
ce qu' ils sont différents justement ces
français qui vont qui vont vers paris
puis vers bruxelles ils sont différents
des canadiens tout en s'inspirant l'on
retrouve ce mot de liberté
écoutez je crois qu'au fil de la
conversation
nous nous rapprochons enfin du sujet
quel est le sujet j'entendais votre
chroniqueuse je crois par les deux déçus
de la démocratie et pas du tout ce sont
des déçus de l'absence de démocratie il
faut quand même rappeler quelques règles
fondamentales
liées à ce terme la démocratie c'est le
consentement c'est le consensus c'est
l'agrégation de la majorité des citoyens
à la fabrication de la décision
politique donc ce que ces pays
incarne ce sont des oligarchies pas des
démocraties lorsqu'on appelle
pudiquement démocratie libérale mais ça
n'a plus qu'un lointain souvenir avec
effectivement le sens je dirais
atteignant 2,2 de la démocratie donc les
gens protestent contre l'absence de
pouvoir de participer à la fabrication
de décision voilà et obligations
évidemment obligation vaccinale en
l'occurrence il est évident que c'est un
mot qui fait tâche dans l'univers de la
démocratie pis comme je le disais la
démocratie ce n'est pas la contrainte la
démocratie c'est le consensus voilà
alors il ne manque qu il ya des
convergences entre
la france et le canada enfin ottawa en
particulier alors d'abord il faut quand
même souligner que les chauffeurs
routiers qui soit indépendant ou pas ne
sont pas des manifestants comme les
autres ce sont des manifestants
puissants ils ont la capacité de bloquer
les routes de bloquer du centre ville 1
le voir on le voit au canada mais on le
voit aussi en france quand il ya des
opérations des opérations escargot voilà
donc encore une fois le fond le
background si vous me permettez ce mot
de cette affaire c'est un monde qui est
en pleine décomposition avec un écart
entre les richesses accumulées par les
uns notamment à l'occasion de la crise
sanitaire et la pauvreté dans laquelle
s'enfonce des millions de gens de par le
monde voilà c'est ça qui ne va pas et
c'est ça qui est insupportable et c'est
serré derrière la colère il ya la
souffrance maintenant il ya beaucoup de
sous produits
martin geoffroy vous êtes d'accord avec
ce que vient de dire michel fize vous
pourriez dire ça également à ottawa que
c'est parce que la population est en
souffrance parce que en fait ils ne se
sentent plus représentés que ce n'est
plus une vraie démocratie
bon le canada est très différent de la
france la demande et les comparaisons
faut arrêter au canada on parlait de
compte monsieur parler de consensus
social moi je pense que par rapport que
ce soit par rapport aux opa sanitaire au
pass vaccinale pardon aux vaccins ya
consensus au canada environ 90% de la
population
s'est fait vacciner à deux doses en a
vacciné les enfants je pense qu'il ya un
consensus là dessus on a on a 60 je
pense plus de 62% de la population qui
est en désaccord avec ce qui se passe en
ce moment à ottawa et dans d'autres
villes canadiennes avec ce qu'on voit de
camionneurs et en passant ya une chose
importante qu'il faut dire
on a été protester contre trudeau parce
qu'il a imposées elles passent vaccinale
pour aller aux états unis mais de
l'autre côté de la frontière joe biden
impose aussi le pass vaccinale donc
quand même que trudeau voudrait enlever
le pass vaccinale pour les camionneurs
ils ne pourraient pas se rendre aux
états unis à ce moment là donc ça ne
change rien higuain est ce qu'il ya une
défiance tout de même à défiance à
l'égard des autorités ou est-ce qu
effectivement le mouvement est beaucoup
plus un mouvement d'extrême droite comme
vous l'aviez décrit sk une défiance plus
globale à l'égard des autorités politico
à ottawa et peut-être plus largement au
canada ben je pense que c'est pas le
même type de défiance qu'en france la
défiance est beaucoup moins quand france
s'est passé parce que vous faites des
comparaisons avec la france en france
vous avez en généralement près de la
moitié de la population qui croît à
diverses théories du complot ici au
canada c'est à peu près 25% de la
population dans tous les sondages qui
croient aux théories du complot donc il
ya beaucoup plus de confiance aux
institutions ici au canada généralement
c'est sûr qu'avec la pandémie cette
confiance-là été relativement ébranlé
mais encore là quand monsieur parle que
il ya beaucoup de pauvreté à cause de la
pandémie au canada le canada est un des
pays qui s'est le mieux de cire et
économiquement de la pandémie c'est à
dire que pour tous les gens qui ont
perdu leur emploi au canada le
gouvernement donnait des prestations
spéciales pour s'en sortir il a donné
aussi beaucoup de deux prestations aux
entreprises et l'économie canadienne
malgré la pandémie se porte extrêmement
bien en ce moment nous avons un taux de
chômage qui est très bas et même je vous
dirais que dans plusieurs métiers il ya
pénurie au canada dans l'enseignement
dans les eaux donc il ya le pénurie
d'emploi d'un pénurie de personnel alors
moi je quand monsieur me raconte qu'il
ya une énorme pauvreté au canada que les
gens se révoltent parce qu' ils ont
écopé de la pandémie bas c'est le
contraire nous sommes très prospère
saint germain vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que vient de dire martin l'offrande
plutôt d'accord avec avec michel fize
est ce qu'il ya une défiance à l'égard
des autorités au canada également
peut-être plus générale que simplement
ce mouvement
alors je serais je dirais un tout petit
peu plus nuancé d'abord sur le fait que
lorsque l'on dit qu'il ya 90% de la
population qui est vacciné c'est vrai
mais ça ne veut pas dire que il y à 90%
de la population qui considère que
l'obligation vaccinale est quelque chose
de d'acceptable il faut se rendre compte
qu'il y à une opposition de plus en plus
grand de au canada face à l'obligation
vaccinale elle est loin d'être
majoritaire mais il y a un certain
nombre de personnes qui soutiennent ce
point d'ailleurs le le principal
représentant du parti libéral canadien
pour le québec le chef des cibles et des
députés québécois du parti libéral
fédéral vient de critiquer très vivement
son chef
justin trudeau quant à la manière dont
la crise est gérée et donc ça c'est un
autre élément sur lequel il faut
insister c'est le fait que c'est
évidemment très difficile de gérer cette
crise mais le gouvernement fédéral a été
très dur en appliquant cette obligation
vaccinale aux camionneurs et bien
honnêtement un certain nombre de
canadiens ne comprennent pas cette
décision faut savoir que l'économie
canadienne est très liée aux états unis
et en obligeant les routiers à être
vaccinés on savait bien qu'un certain
nombre d'entre eux à les refuser et que
ça allait proposer des problèmes
d'approvisionnement alors on en est pas
encore là mais il est clair qu'un
certain nombre de canadiens sont
critiques par rapport à ça faut savoir
que le premier ministre a été
relativement discret alors il ya eu
différentes raisons il a été touché lui
aussi par l'aco vide mais globalement il
a été très discret dans cette crise
aussi parce que c'est très difficile à
gérer pour se rendre compte que à ottawa
on considère d'abord que ce sont les
autorités d'ottawa qui doivent gérer
mais la police d'ottawa est complètement
débordé au dessus d'elle il y a le
gouvernement provincial mais le
gouvernement provincial est quasi aux
abonnés absents et donc il renvoie vers
le gouvernement fédéral et le
gouvernement fédéral et est très prudent
parce qu'il faut se rendre compte que
que peut-on faire face à des routiers
certains l'ont dit ils ont démonté leurs
pneus et où ils sont très difficiles à
bouger alors on pourrait envoyer l'armée
mais on a des souvenirs de l'envoi de
l'armée par un autre trudeau le père de
justin en 1970 en octobre soit 110 au
québec ça avait mal tourné et donc on
sent que tout le monde est très mal pris
dans cette histoire mais c'est vrai
qu'il y à une défiance d'une partie de
la population canadienne non pas par
rapport aux institutions démocratiques
et donc il faut pas mélanger ces
mouvements d'extrême droite qui sont
présents là et qui veulent effectivement
la disparition quasi de la démocratie
canadienne et un certain nombre de
canadiens qui dé tout à fait démocrates
mais qui considère que la manière dont
la crise est gérée pour le moment pose
problème à tort ou à raison mais il faut
savoir que c'est un c'est quelque chose
qui est en train de se développer et
surtout à un moment où dans toute une
série de pays il faut bien le
reconnaître on est en train de reculer
sur l'obligation vaccinale nous sommes
ici je suis ici en belgique
voici quelques semaines on parlait de
l'obligation vaccinale aujourd'hui elle
semble quelque chose que l'on ne va pas
imposer à l'ensemble de la population
alors on n'a pas imposé à l'ensemble de
la population canada mais elle imposer
un groupe comme ça ça peut poser
problème on voit bien l'embarras bien
sûr des autorités politiques de justin
trudeau c'est vrai que le mouvement
toute façon il ya toujours une forme de
politisation en france un déjà la france
a soumises a dit qu'elle soutenait ce
mouvement dont qui se constitue autour
de ses convois on va écouter justement
adrien à quatre mains ce numéro deux de
la fin des insoumis
il nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
l'idée que soit maintenue durablement
des logiques liberticides comme celles
que l'on voit qui d'ailleurs ne sont pas
en mesure je vais pas vous refaire toute
la discussion qu'on a des 5300 sert de
rejoindre ces convois mais à écouter
faut voir la liste des revendications
dans le détail mais s'il s'agit de
défendre la liberté de dire qu'on doit
abroger le pass vaccinale oui je vous le
dit d'ailleurs je vous le dit jean luc
mélenchon élu au mois d'avril n'attendra
pas l'été canada sur le pass vacances et
sur le verre aussi la question du
pouvoir d'achat en france et j'ai vu
certains qui ont l'intention d'utiliser
ces convois pour en quelque sorte
revenir avec des revendications qui
n'ont pas été satisfaites des gilet
jaune est évidemment que nous le
soutenons toujours bienvenu on a deux
mois du des élections présidentielles
donc forcément ça a un impact marine le
pen elle a dit comprendre ce mouvement
donc ça risque peut-être de compliquer
un petit peu aussi cette campagne en
tout cas sa sincère ça s'immisce dans la
campagne mais en tout cas c'est sûr que
c'est ce que craint le gouvernement
français avec emmanuel macron en
particulier avec effectivement cette
expérience
ddj les jaunes donc le ministre de
l'intérieur et sur le que sur le qui
vive peut-être juste pour réagir
effectivement il ya deux revendications
2 de thèmes de ces de ce mouvement il ya
la liberté la liberté de ne pas se
vacciner et la revendiquer et laquelle à
la protestation aussi contre la hausse
des prix du pétrole en particulier ce
sont essentiellement des voitures du
covoiturage qui va qui vont former qui
vont former ce convoi kragbé différence
avec les canada avec le canada on n'est
pas sont pas ce ne sont pas des
chauffeurs routiers des chauffeurs
routiers effectivement les syndicats
français de camionneurs n'ont pas appelé
à manifester
les situations sont très différentes les
camionneurs en france n'ont pas besoin
de passes vaccinale pour traverser les
frontières mais ce qui est quand même le
parallèle et je rebondis quand même sur
ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur la
défiance de la démocratie ou de la
démocratie libérale pour préciser
effectivement et pour répondre à michel
fize il y a effectivement cette pandémie
a ébranlé la confiance des citoyens
envers ceux qui les gouvernent pourquoi
parce que eux-mêmes ont été ont pris un
moment donné des décisions à l'aveuglé
n'ont pas forcément reconnu qu'il ne
savait pas exactement quoi prendre comme
décision ils ont pris parfois aussi des
décisions incohérentes
sans forcément reconnaître derrière que
oui dans une pandémie comme ça qui est
inédite parfois on ne sait pas
véritablement et le fait de ne pas dire
on ne sait pas à plonger beaucoup de
citoyens dans l'incompréhension la plus
totale et quand on ne comprend pas et
ben on essaie tout simplement de trouver
l'explication parfois la plus simple et
on verse parfois dans le complotisme où
c'est enfin voila c'est le sait aussi
c'est aussi ce qui peut se produire ce
moment martin geoffroy vous avez été
surpris que le mouvement fasse tache
d'huile d'abord en nouvelle zélande et
maintenant en france peut-être dans
d'autres pays
bas je pense qu'on copie tout simplement
quelque chose qui semble une formule qui
semble avoir vu du succès mais quand il
ya des énormes différences là dans ce
que vous dites avec la france parce que
ici là c'est pas un mouvement gauche ans
parce que les partis de gauche ici que
ce soit le npd au fédéral ou québec
solidaire au québec ils sont pour le pas
finale ils sont pour les mesures
sanitaires c'est vraiment un mouvement
au canada qui est contre l'ensemble des
mesures sanitaires qui vient de la
droite et surtout de l'extrême droite
alors s'il n'y a pas de rapport avec le
mouvement qui est en train de naître en
france qui est qui est aussi à gauche
qu'à droite finalement
ici c'est tu es aussi quand on parle
spécifiquement de ce qui est arrivé à
ottawa
c'est beaucoup plus une mauvaise
organisation policière qui
a fait en sorte que l'on se retrouve
avec avec ce gâchis aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya eu le même type de
manifestation à québec le week-end passé
et ça s'est très bien passé ils sont
allés deux jours ils ont manifesté et
ils sont repartis pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement du québec et la mairie de
québec se sont organisés pour
maîtriser les camions pour ne pas qu'ils
rentrent dans la capitale et ça s'est
très bien passé à ottawa ils ont été
dépassés c'est comme s'ils n'avaient pas
venu pas vu venir les mouvements
extrémistes et encore une fois je le
rappelle
oui il ya beaucoup de gens parmi les
gens d'ottawa qui sont peut-être des
camionneurs mais c'est une infime
minorité c'est vraiment un agrégat de
groupes de pression politique en tout
genre et on se sert finalement
de
dudu on se sert du problème de la
problématique des camionneurs qui
maintenant loin derrière on se sert de
cette problématique là pour finalement
faire avancer son agenda politique est
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui en alberta le
premier ministre jason kenney a dit
qu'il levait le
le parce que c'était plus nécessaire le
pass
le pass vaccinale alors bon dans un
contexte où au canada en ce moment on
est en train de descons fine et
moi je trouve que tous dans tous ces
débats là sur la démocratie on oublie
une chose est une chose importante
c'est les recommandations de la santé
publique et il et c'est là que le
complotisme arrive en jeu parce que
quand on est rendu parce que c'est ça
qui arrive en ce moment au canada et
ailleurs peut-être dans d'autres pays on
verse me renverse dans le populisme et
moi ce que j'ai peur c'est que les
gouvernements réagissent justement à
l'intimidation à la vindicte populaire
et n'écoute plus les conseils d experts
et de la santé publique parce que ce
sont eux les experts du virus et de la
pandémie c'est pas vous c'est pas moi
alors moi je pense qu'il faut suivre les
recommandations de la santé publique et
si on parle des camionneurs qui ont dit
qu'ils veulent pas nuire à l'économie
que ça nuit à l'économie que les les
camionneurs canadien ne puisse pas
traversé la frontière en ce moment vous
avez un groupe de camionneurs qui
bloquent le pont de windsor au canada
qui est un point extrêmement important
pour justement le transport des denrées
entre le canada et les états unis alors
s'ils ne veulent pas s ils disent que ça
nuit à l'économie pourquoi ils sont en
train et même de nuire à l'économie en
bloquant une artère très importante pour
pour le transport des denrées entre le
canada les etats-unis oui alors moi je
pense que c'est pas on est rendu à autre
chose on est rendu à on veut remettre en
question la démocratie libérale parce
qu'il ya des groupes à ottawa qui ont
proposé qui ont carrément rédiger une
nouvelle constitution
dans laquelle ils deviendraient les mots
qu'ils ont une menace à la démocratie
pour vous ces mouvements oui ces
mouvements d'extrême droit de là sont
des mouvements qui sont une menace pour
la démocratie et ottawa en ce moment
c'est un siège 1 c'est pas quelque chose
ce n'est pas une manifestation ordinaire
c'est un siège la police comme vous
disiez tout à l'heure n'a plus le
contrôle alors moi je trouve que
franchement je vais et je vais dire le
mot on est à deux doigts de terrorisme
un serge dom à vous êtes d'accord avec
martin geoffroy justement dans cette
danse est
cet arbitrage à faire entre liberté
santé ce qui viennent dire justement
parlons de siège de menaces de la
démocratie
alors donc c'est clair que effectivement
on est dans un moment problématique au
niveau de la démocratie alors je
voudrais tout de même souligner
plusieurs choses donc c'est vrai on dit
que ça a été mieux gérer à québec qu'à
ottawa mais il faut savoir que lorsque
les camions sont arrivés à québec il
était déjà ottawa depuis un moment donc
la police a pu gérer les choses
autrement ce qui concerne le pont qui
est bloqué évidemment c'est une volonté
forte des des camionneurs finalement de
paralyser l'économie c'est assez clair
mais c'est une petite minorité là dessus
on est d'accord ce sont des camionneurs
avec toute une série de personnes autour
d'eux ils sont même venus avec leurs
familles et tous mais un certain nombre
d'entre eux sont donc vraiment des
camionneurs très engagé dans la lutte
c'est vrai qu'on a vu fleurir toute une
série de messages d'extrême droite de
messages aussi raciste et autres à toute
une série de choses très désagréable que
l'on a vu là ceci dit à nouveau je
voudrai tout de même souligner qu' il
n'y a pas que l'extrême droite qui est
opposé
à l'obligation vaccinale il y à aussi au
canada je le rappelle un certain nombre
de d'élus et d'élus de gauche et
notamment donc un représentant du parti
libéral qui a pris très clairement ses
distances par rapport à son premier
ministre il ya un véritable débat ce qui
est vrai c'est que là on a donc des
groupes d'extrême droite et quand vous
demandiez quels sont les liens d'un pays
à l'autre on n'a pas encore souligné
mais il faut tout de même se dire que il
y a aussi probablement une volonté de
réfléchir à ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis
voici quelques temps et donc on pense on
a en tête évidemment le 6 janvier 2020
et ce n'est pas par hasard si donald
trump a salué et son fils également les
manifestants au canada c'est parce que
pour eux il y à là quelque chose qui
ressemble à ce qu'ils ont voulu faire
aux états unis et moi j'ai un petit peu
l'impression que c'est le modèle
américain cette société très divisés
qu'on essaie d'exporter au canada avec
peu de succès il faut le il faut être
d'accord là dessus un succès
comment diviser mais ottawa est toujours
bloquée oui mais c'était
oui c'est exact mais enfin donc c'est le
centre d'ottawa et c'est une petite
minorité qui est là bien entendu mais il
y a une volonté de faire pression sur
les institutions démocratiques comme on
a voulu le faire aux états unis mais
globalement la société canadienne n'est
pas couper au couteau comme vous l'avez
aux états unis avec deux bulles qui ne
se parlent quasiment pas une grande
majorité de la population est très
clairement derrière les mesures
vaccinale derrière le premier ministre
ça me fait pas l'ombre d'un doute mais
il faut savoir que des élus tout à fait
démocratique comme des élus du parti
conservateur qui sont pas du tout
d'extrême droite son action très à
droite mais ce n'est pas l'extrême
droite soutiennent un certain nombre
d'éléments qui sont donnés par les
camionneurs et donc on a vu certains
utilisé le slogan mais cannes et air
canada great games on a vu des drames
ses techniciens mentalisation un joli
c'était une instrumentalisation
politique
il est très à huy très probablement il
est clair qu'il ya un certain nombre de
groupes d'extrême droite qui ont profité
de cette occasion parce que ils ont peu
de moyens de se faire entendre surtout
au canada et dont qu'ils utilisent cette
possibilité d'avoir les médias canadiens
mais finalement aussi les médias du
monde entier qui sont en train de les
regarder on fait une émission sert à
chauffer une amy ce qu'on fasse une
émission sur ottawa donc du coup ils
utilisent cela pour se faire valoir et
pour mettre en avant assez un nombre
d'idées qui ne sont pas partagées par
l'ensemble de la population canadienne
donc c'est une toute petite minorité
mais il bénéficie d'une caisse de
résonance extraordinaire et donc ils
s'utilisent la question du pass vaccine
de la l'obligation vaccinale pour faire
valoir leurs revendications
virginie on peut dire tout ce que ça
révèle un petit peu tous ces mouvements
qu'on a retrouvé d'ailleurs anti
passante ivax les fractures de la
société oui les fractures de la société
tout à l'heure je disais les fractures
de des démocraties des démocraties
libérales le la constestation enfin le
manque de confiance ou la défiance des
citoyens envers ceux qui les gouvernent
envers les institutions par parfois
manque de cohérence on voit enfin on
peut faire le parallèle aussi sur les
élections sur l'abstention par exemple
qu effectivement et là ça va être
intéressant de suivre en france comme en
commun qui va voter qui va se mobiliser
pour voter qui va aller qui va aller
dans la rue est-ce que là c'est un
nouvelle région urgence du mouvement des
gilet jaune il ya quand même l'aspect
économique on a relativement peu traitée
dans cette émission qui est quand même
l'augmentation du prix de l'énergie
suite à cette à cette pandémie qui
divise la société effectivement tout à
l'heure une seule fils pendent aimerait
bien l'avoir avec nous mais challes
fille voilà le heureusement ils skient
voilà qui soumit effectivement que les
la différence est la différence entre
économique entre les plus riches et les
plus pauvres étaient en train de se
creuser
ça aussi c'est en train de saper les
fondements de la démocratie et c'est
peut-être un phare éléments positifs en
francs et des manques on retrouve dans
ces différents mouvements avec
évidemment dans chaque pays des
spécificités dieu alors ces systèmes
politiques et notamment le fédéralisme
au canada martin geoffroy pour pour
conclure j'ai fait un dernier petit tour
de table ça révèle vraiment des
fractures tout de même au sein de la
société canadienne ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
bien sûr que c'est un révèle des
fractures et une étude une recherche que
nous avons publié il ya un an
sur les événements reliés à l'extrême
droite au québec et la violence de 2010
à 2020 a montré à montrer que ces
événements au québec et aussi au canada
et est en augmentation
significative et que l'année 2020 qui
avait été la première année de la
pandémie avait été l'année où il y avait
eu le plus d'actes de violence au québec
et au canada relier à l'extrême droite
donc ce qu'on constate en ce moment
c'est un point culminant de ces
tactiques d'intimidation t'utilises des
mouvements d'extrême-droite au canada et
aussi le fait que depuis la pandémie
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
ces mouvements là ont trouvé le moyen de
fédérer de faire du recrutement parmi
des gens qui habituellement n'avait pas
nécessairement de rapport avec eux mais
de les fédérer dans dans les mesures
anti sanitaire coincé entre le jeune
homme serge aubin saint jaume à ce que
vous pouvez conclure effectivement aussi
sur cette facture s'est fracturé peut
être révélée par ses goûts ce groupe ce
oui bien dans ce siège ce sont des
fractures qui qu'ils se sont des
fractures qui existent dans toutes lés
dans toutes les sociétés elles sont
probablement moins
marquée dans la société canadienne que
dans d'autres sociétés mais elle existe
et s'est fracturé soit en quelque sorte
aggravée par la situation économique
parce qu'il est bien vrai que là la
crise sanitaire a eu des conséquences
économiques très graves pour un certain
nombre de populations même si on sait
que les gouvernements et notamment le
gouvernement canadien a fait beaucoup
pour aider les les personnes les plus
pauvres les plus démunis il ya une
véritable on a senti clairement ce
qu'était un état qui étaient attentifs à
ces populations et il ya là quelque
chose effectivement ici d'intéressant
parce que en voyant cesser ces gros
camions devant le parlement d'ottawa et
bien cela pose un certain nombre de
questions et ça ouvre le débat
certainement merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir participé à ce débat ce soir
serge aubin merci à vous martin geoffroy
merci à michel fize qui mène
manifestement malheureusement n'a pas pu
rester avec nous pendant toute
l'émission merci virginie merci à
françois henry wayne notre correspondant
au canada merci à vous tous nos autres
suivi reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]